[Music]
we're gonna go to louisville kentucky
with jason hey jason how are you
hey guys i'm good how are you guys today
great what's going on
good good hey thanks so much for taking
my call and thanks for all that you guys
do sure thank you i
have i i have been
uh kind of on and off the ramsey uh
journey for
many years but i am finally finally uh
debt free awesome completely debt free
and yeah it um thank you so much it's
it's taken a lot of uh uh stopping and
starting and and a lot of life happening
uh to finally get me to this place but
um and i'm super thankful and super
grateful for uh for being here um and my
question is this um i actually am um
going to be getting married um in the
next year sometime in the next year
this is going to be a second marriage
for myself and
my fiance
and
she also is completely debt free
including her house
she's worked very hard uh to get there
as a school teacher um similar to the
previous call actually yeah and um
uh in just a really really good
financial position um
as we go to get married
um obviously our lives are gonna combine
with with no debt um we will ultimately
live in her home
and my struggle is this i i guess maybe
i just need maybe some insight or some
encouragement or something here but
i'm struggling a little bit with the
idea that i
just am not uh going to be a major
contributor
to our deaf free life
we'll be moving into her home it's about
a half a million dollar home that's paid
for
um it lots of money saved i've got a
little bit saved as well but i'm just
struggling with the idea that um
i'm kind of stepping into a situation
where i
i don't really have to do anything uh to
to
to to contribute to a
financially free life
and um
you know i've lived most of my life sort
of in conflict and trying to figure out
how to pay bills and all this and that
and finally getting to a place now where
i'm debt-free and
you know loving that
um but just feeling like
i don't know it just it's a struggle for
me to step into
a marriage
and be a beneficiary of all of her hard
work
um and i don't really contribute to that
and so i don't know it's it's a very
strange place in my life and i don't
know if you guys would have any insight
or thoughts to just kind of
give me a boost here with that yeah well
thank you for calling uh we'd love to
talk through this with you i have a
question about your fiance
um
how how does she act about the money
piece of this with you is this something
that she is like um it's our money this
is our life or is just is this something
that in any way she holds it over your
head or is there anything that you feel
bad because of her because of the way
that she treats it
no
not at all um it's very much the the
first she
um
uh is
incredibly gracious and sweet and kind
and
does not hold it over you know my head
at all
um
i'll be bringing a little bit more of a
of a savings account to our to our life
together
um
but again you know
it doesn't really compare much to um
what she's done but no not at all i mean
there's there's no hanging over my head
whatsoever yeah um i think we're both
just equally excited to be able to have
a life together yeah um but i i think
it's more my struggle than hers for sure
jason
where is this coming from this level of
like this is a competition who's
bringing more to the marriage who's done
what financially where does that stem
from do you think for you personally
you know i came out of a really bad
marriage um
and i i wouldn't
be shocked um if a therapist
told me that it stemmed from that
um i i i struggle with with that
a lot you know just the idea that there
is some level of of competition although
that that sort of paints it in a
little bit of a negative light and i i
don't feel
you know i don't really feel
the competition per se but it's just
um
i don't know i think as a man um as a
you know a provider it just is
it just is a struggle i i guess well and
i think you bring it up an interesting
point jason because even being from i
mean even living in kentucky like i live
in the south i've grown up in the south
there is a cultural thing to what you're
saying i think you can see that in
church too for people that are believers
so that whether that's spoken or
unspoken i can see that you feel this
pressure to
your words be the provider and there's
different value systems and different uh
gosh there's lots of different stances
on that but the thing that i'm just
excited for you is i'm excited that you
have this new relationship you are
excited about the future your fiance is
excited about the future and you guys
are debt-free and set up really well
when you walk down the aisle it's gonna
be we
we what are we gonna do and it becomes
y'all's home together and it's
everything is about the future the past
is in the past and i know it's easy to
say that it may be something you do want
to dig into and and counseling that type
of thing we all have baggage we bring to
anything that we do um whether it's a
second marriage or you get married later
in life or childhood or whatever but i'm
just um i will just tell you from from
an outsider's perspective i think that
all of the things that can be right are
right your spouse is supportive you're
coming into a great situation you're
bringing a lot to the situation and i
don't want you to underestimate that um
financially but also just um you know
from who you are as a person we are a
lot more than our bank accounts and you
will bring a lot to the marriage that is
more than your bank account and so i
just want to encourage you i think that
you have so much to look forward to and
i think that if anything that guilt or
shame or whatever is something that can
be worked through and it's worth it to
work through it because i don't think
you need to live under that cloud i
think that you're in a great situation
and certainly there's nothing even to
work through on the side of your fiance
where it's some unhealthy
dynamic of her holding it over you um i
think this is probably like you said
either from
wounds or um the cultural pressure to be
some idea of what a man is or what a
husband is and i think that um you and
your fiance get to define what your
family is and you get to define what
your future is and and i'm excited for
you jason i think that i think that
you're doing great and and maybe it's
worth leaning into with like i said with
some
some counseling to dig into that even
with your with your fiance and say hey
what do we believe about money and how
do we feel about this and and so on but
i think i think you're doing better than
you think you are yeah and christy this
all points to one thing that your worth
is not your net worth and i think as men
it's easy to tie your performance and
your income to how am i doing as a
husband as a father as a friend
and when you take all that away and you
strip it away and go no what does it
mean to be a great husband what does it
mean to be on a team with my wife as we
step into this amazing new chapter and
guess what the money part is really not
a huge part of the equation because of
the financial position that you guys
have put yourselves in remember you did
a lot of hard work you shared your
debt-free story with us and what it took
to get there
so don't step into this thing thinking
i'm not bringing anything to the table
you're bringing worth eq work ethic
you're bringing character you're
bringing so much more than just a number
yeah
yeah and the and you and you also like
you said you also do have the finances
you have the savings account you have
you have both and uh and so i think what
we're just we just want to encourage you
that yes you're doing better than you
think you are and uh it's a great
question to ask i'm glad you called um
but it's something i think you should
lean into i think you and your fiance
can walk through this together talk
through it together and it will bring
you even closer and by the way y'all are
in a great position financially y'all
are doing great this is the ramsay show